[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
well good morning or good afternoon
everyone welcome uh
let's give a round of applause to las
vegas high school mariachi band
led by steven blanco thank you guys so
much for being here
[Applause]
so welcome to the official kickoff of
the nevada recovers tour my name is
kirsten and i will introduce now brian
batista he's a student of the mariachi
band and he's going to lead us in the
pledge of allegiance
at this moment please join us for the
pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance for which it stands
one nation into the republic
for which it stands one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you brian so here to tell us more
about the opportunities presented by the
american rescue plan act and the
recovery tour is governor steve
sissellat governor
[Applause]
thank you and again a shout out to the
mariachi band
they're going from here this weekend
they're playing at luxor and then
caesar's palace so if you talk about a
step up
that is great guys i'm really proud of
you congratulations
good afternoon everyone it's really nice
to be here with you today
right in the heart of east las vegas
i've got a few dignitaries i want to
introduce
i know i know an awful lot of people
here and i'm so proud to know so many of
you but i've got
a few that i think we need to draw some
additional attention to
uh senator mo dennis and senator chris
brooks are with us and we thank you guys
for being here
also councilwoman olivia diaz is here
and speaker barbara buckley has also
joined us today so thank you all
and they've got a lot of chambers
present which is really
really great i mean uh urban chamber of
the latin chamber the henderson chamber
the las vegas chamber
a metro chamber it's just amazing
because you're where we're gonna really
need a lot of help
and we appreciate your willingness to
get involved and to help us get input
in these areas i want to thank the
community leaders that are here
for joining us this afternoon to embark
on one of the biggest opportunities
in the state of nevada's history before
we get started i want to recognize just
one or two more people
a very very special young lady who i am
so incredibly proud of
juliana air today is nevada's very first
national national teacher of the year
i mean it was so exciting when the first
lady and i don't mean my wife i mean
president biden's wife got to be here in
honor juliana it was such an exciting
day and we're so incredibly proud of you
and everything that you do every day
representing educators representing the
great state of nevada
thank you very much i also got my great
friend
uh congresswoman dina titus is with us
you'll hear from her shortly
[Applause]
and then we're going to hear from
treasure zach conan and i can tell you
uh i don't even know how to put an award
treasurer conan has been on the front
lines of this recovery effort he helped
us with the pets program
he is there at the drop of a hat to help
any way possible
he never asks he never questions you
says what can i do how can i help and we
are so thankful
zach that we've got you and your entire
office that have done such an incredible
job
uh additionally we've got so many of our
non-profits here today
that are represented in this community
and we want to thank you as well
i believe as i said some of the
legislature are introduced
we created every nevada recovery
framework
in partnership with legislative
leadership majority leader
canazarro and assembly speaker jason
fryerson were instrumental
in helping make this a reality and we
thank them for this
as we move forward in this process i'm
excited
for our lawmakers to be able to engage
with their constituents
and help bring more voices to the table
as we embark
on a truly once in a lifetime
opportunity for our state
not to spend but to invest in our future
and create a more resilient nevada a
nevada for everyone
it's no secret nevada was particularly
hard hit
during the pandemic coveted 19 that
we've dealt with
covet forced us to operate under new
reality over the last year
but we're finally starting to see a
light at the end of the tunnel
and as our communities get vaccinated
we're putting people back to work
and rebuilding our economy that was
devastated by the pandemic
i'm going to throw the plug here i'm
going off script if you haven't been
vaccinated
please consider getting vaccinated if
you've got questions we've got staff you
can ask you can ask the medical
community
it's safe it's effective and it's free
so if you haven't been vaccinated please
consider getting the vaccine if you have
been vaccinated
get a neighbor a friend or a colleague
or someone to go get vaccinated because
that's the only way we're going to end
this pandemic once and for all
with the passage of the american rescue
plan we now have an unprecedented and i
mean unprecedented opportunity in front
of us
we have billions of dollars with b
billions of dollars in federal funding
available to help us rebuild recover our
economy from government 19
which is this represents the largest
investment
that the federal government has ever
made in the state of nevada
billions of dollars that we're going to
work to spend not to spend to invest in
a way that's going to benefit us all
well it may be tempting to try and spend
this money
quickly make headlines and get it out
there
we have responsibility to make sure that
this money is
invested deliberately and intentionally
so that we can build a better lifestyle
a better nevada
for not just us but for generations to
come and that's our intention to do just
that
to ensure that these dollars are
invested in the most transparent
effective way possible
we must take the needs of our
communities into account
so we can make our recovery as strong
and as equitable as possible
that's what this listening tour that
treasurer conan is embarking on is set
up
is all about is listening to our
communities their opinions their needs
their desires and their ideas
i'm excited to announce that beginning
today we are kicking off the nevada
recovers listening tour
this will be the largest and most robust
effort to get feedback
directly from residents across our state
thanks to the work of my office and
state treasurer conine
we are now ready to embark on this
75-day
tour to recover from the pandemic and to
take
build a state that we can all be proud
of i'd like to have a short video played
which will outline what nevadans can
expect
from this tour over the next 15 months
next few months not 15. it's kind of
going to be two and a half sorry exactly
it's two and a half months i'm not
giving
off this yeah okay go ahead i think
we've been faced with impossible choices
i've been without a job for over a year
and it has been so difficult i
am behind my rent and i just worry about
my family and i
are going to get evicted as a special
education teacher
i get to help students who need
individualized supports in the classroom
i love my job but this last year was a
challenge to ensure
all of my students were engaging in
virtual learning since they couldn't be
in the classroom safely
i am proud to do my part to keep my
students safe
[Music]
throughout the pandemic nevadans have
found themselves facing impossible
situations
they've had to make incredible
sacrifices
but thanks to the dedication of our
residents alongside the robust
vaccination campaign that's underway
we are beginning to recover and rebuild
our state
which was devastated by the economic
effects of the pandemic
coveted 19 exposed cracks in our social
safety net
as nevada families were in need of
emergency unemployment benefits
food assistance and help with their rent
and utility bills
but let's get one thing clear covid
covid19 didn't create these problems
they have existed for decades and
generations before this pandemic
for too long we have under invested in
vital programs and services
that help to increase opportunities for
nevadans as a result we've consistently
found ourselves at the bottom of every
bad list
this ends today we have too many kids in
too many crowded classrooms
our lack of affordable housing has
resulted in skyrocketing rent
while homeownership is becoming
increasingly out of reach
we have thousands of workers living
paycheck to paycheck
who are in need of training programs
that will help them find
good paying jobs fortunately we now have
the opportunity to do something for
nevadans that we've never done before
with the passage of the american rescue
plan the state of nevada is set to
receive more than 11 billion dollars in
funding
to help support working families and
small businesses who've been so hard hit
by the coronavirus pandemic
the funding i helped secure is the
single largest infusion of federal
dollars into our state
in history we have a unique opportunity
not only to recover from the devastating
impacts of this pandemic but to also
build a stronger more resilient economy
where every nevadan has a seat at the
table by listening to the voices of
nevada's and working together
with federal state and local officials
we can develop a plan to invest directly
into our communities
and uplift hard-working families that's
why we're hitting the road
and going on a listening tour over 75
days so we can go directly into
communities
meet people where they are and listen to
how they think these dollars should be
spent
through town halls community meetings
and some hard conversations with real
people
we'll better understand the challenges
that nevadans face every day
as we work to find long-term solutions
towards building the nevada we deserve
it's going to take all of us to make
sure that the economic damage of the
last year
never happens again but by working
collaboratively with our community
partners
we can ensure that working families have
the resources that they need
to put food on the table and recover
from this pandemic
stronger than ever we must make sure
that our veterans
people with disabilities and our tribal
communities
always have a seat at the table when
we're having discussions about
funding by investing these federal
dollars directly into the community
we can ensure that they're spent in the
most transparent
and effective way possible throughout
nevada we need to do more to address our
crumbling infrastructure
because of the american rescue plan we
can now create
thousands of good paying jobs while
fighting the effects of climate change
we can also work to build our broadband
and our most vulnerable communities
so that everyone has access to reliable
internet
and no one gets left behind nevada's
restaurants bars
venues and small businesses were hit
especially hard during this pandemic
but through a partnership between
washington the state
and local leaders we were able to
deliver
much needed relief but we know that we
still have much more work to do
now that we're coming out of this
pandemic it's going to take all of us
working together to rebuild our state
into what we know it can be
i'm incredibly proud to launch this
statewide listening tour
and i'm encouraging every nevadan to
join us and make their voices heard
it's not going to be easy and i'm sure
we're going to have difficult
conversations along the way
we have a responsibility to use these
federal dollars as effectively as
possible
i hope you'll join us over the next few
months as we work to build a more
resilient state
for the next generation of nevadans
let's get to work
[Applause]
thank you and zach that is uh incredible
video you did an absolutely phenomenal
job
your team uh if we could have the
treasurer's office team stand up i mean
you just got erica okay okay
over here okay thanks for everything
guys you were absolutely incredible i am
amazingly incredibly proud of the
sacrifices that nevadans have made
throughout this pandemic in the face of
insurmountable odds
we came together to protect our most
vulnerable members of our community and
now
the real work begins with this federal
funding
we have an opportunity that we've never
had before
to fix systemic problems that have
existed for decades
i'm hopeful that everyone here today
will help solve some of these
long-standing problems in our states
of course none of these federal dollars
would have been available to us
without the efforts of nevada's
congressional delegation
in washington d.c and dina we thank you
for that